so let's look now at the mathematical
foundations of probability theory the
basic definitions of which we've just
been doing examples up until now so a
key concept is a probability space and
that's what we're going to talk about in
this segment so this the abstract
setting of a probability space is the
first thing you start off with is the
set of outcomes which is what we were
saw we were doing with the tree models
in the previous videos and the condition
that we require is that there should be
a countable set of outcomes so there's
something called the sample space and
the sample space is designed to describe
to model all the possible things that
can happen as the result of your random
experiment all the possible outcomes and
we required that there be a countable
number now the examples that we've seen
so far have only had a finite number but
we will shortly see a bunch of examples
where we really need an infinite number
but only a countable infinite number
that's part of the definition of a
probability space the set of outcomes
the next thing is a probability function
whose task is to assign probabilities to
the outcomes so the condition is that
the probability function PR gives the
every element in s every outcome is
going to be assigned a probability of
between 0 and 1 inclusive yeah so every
outcome gets a probability between 0 and
1 and but the constraint on the
probability function is that if I sum up
with the probabilities of all the
outcomes Omega R is an outcome in the
sample space s and I take the sum of all
of those probabilities of Omega they
have to sum to 1 that's the crucial
condition that defines a probability
function on a probability on a sample
space and the two together are what are
called a probability space a sample
space with a probability function is a
probability space so the purpose of the
tree model that we were using is really
to figure out which probability space to
use and the math the mathematics doesn't
really start until you have the
probability space up until that it's the
modeling part that's very important
automatically but you can't say that the
model is right or wrong it's a model and
it's rightness or wrongness is a matter
of judgment and comparison to how it it
stacks up against reality and things
that we care about when we're using the
tree model it's the leaves of the tree
that correspond to the outcomes and the
outcome probabilities which are crucial
for having a probability space we got by
reasoning about the probabilities to
assign to each possible branch of the
tree as you worked your way from root to
leaf so the other key concept that we
saw already is the idea of an event an
event formally is nothing but a subset
of the sample space it's the event is
some set of outcomes presumably the
event is an event that you're interested
in like winning and the definition of
the probability of an event is simply
the sum of the probabilities of all the
outcomes in the event and we were using
this already for both Monty Hall and for
the poker hands but this is the official
general definition that once we have a
probability function that assigns
probabilities to outcomes then we can
use that to define the probability of an
event this is the definition of the
probability of an event is simply the
sum of the outcome probabilities and as
an immediate corollary of this
definition what we get is something
that's central to probability theory
it's called the sum rule and it says
that if you have a bunch of events that
are pairwise disjoint so there's no
outcome in common to a zero in it or a 1
or a 1 and or a 2 and so on then the
probability of the union of the a is the
probability that one of these events
occurs one or more of these events
occurs is simply the sum of the
individual probabilities and that is a
rule that we'll be using all the time
it's very convenient for computing
things if you just break them up into
into separate cases then you can handle
the separate cases each a 0 a 1
separately and then add up the
probabilities
and in some approaches of probability
more general ones this is actually taken
as an axiom
it's the axiom that defines a
probability space but where you start
with an assignment of probabilities
events but in the discrete case we don't
have to worry about that
it's a corollary of the way we define
the probability and that of course is a
crucial rule the sum rule sometimes
called a countable sum rule but we're
just gonna call it the sum rule
expressed in concise notation it's the
probability of the union of the AIS as
AI ranges over the non-negative integers
is simply the sum of the individual
probabilities of those events
now why it's called discrete probability
that we're studying is because we have a
countable sample space and as we saw
that sort of discrete combinatorics is
is the combinatorial countable and even
finite sets really the crucial reason
why we're sticking to discrete
probability is that allows us to work
with sums instead of integrals if you
start allowing continuous intervals of
time and the probability say of throwing
a dart and it landing in a given
interval on the line and a whole bunch
of other situations where it's natural
to want to use continuous probabilities
you're forced into defining a
probability in terms of integrals
because every outcome has probability 0
and the theoretical basis of it is
considerably more complicated and we
don't need it firm in fact virtually any
purposes that come up in computer
science and so we will happily not have
to study integral calculus or measure
theory really and just get by with sums
so let's quickly point out some rules
that are now corollaries that really
derived rules of probability theory that
follow as a consequence of the countable
sum rule and the first one is the
difference rule the probability of a
minus B is simply equal to the
probability of a minus the probability
of a intersection B now notice how much
this looks like the difference rule for
cardinalities that the cardinality of
the finite set a minus B is simply the
cardinality of a minus
the cardinality of a intersection B and
indeed the proof of this is just like
the proof of cardinality it follows
directly from the sum rule for
probabilities which corresponds of
course to the sum rule for cardinalities
namely by the sum rule for probabilities
what we know is that the a is equal sets
theoretically to a intersection B plus a
minus B that is a breaks up into the
points that it has in common with B and
the points that it doesn't have in
common with B since those are disjoint
you can add them so the probability of a
is equal to the probability of a
intersection B plus probability of a
minus B and so I just transpose the a
minus B to the left-hand side and I get
the difference rule which is a rule
that's worth remembering similarly we
have inclusion exclusion the if a and B
are not disjoint then the probability of
a union B is equal to the probability of
a plus the probability of B minus the
probability of the intersection and the
proof is in fact exactly like the
corresponding rule for cardinalities of
finite sets and of course it generalizes
two more sets this is an example of the
inclusion exclusion for three sets in
terms of probability another useful it
turns out consequence is that the
probability that a or B happens is
guaranteed to be less than or equal to
the probability that a happens plus the
probability of B happens and this
follows is a trivial consequence of the
inclusion exclusion rule for two sets
because the probability of a union B is
equal to this Plus this minus some
probability namely the probability of
the intersection so you're taking away
something non-negative from these two in
order to equal that in particular then
this must be less than or equal to that
and the closely related phenomena is
base
the probability that a or B happens is
greater than or equal to the probability
that a happens and finally we can
generalize that to a countable
collection of sets if I have a bunch of
events a 0 a 1 and so on
then the probability that at least one
of them occurs the probability of the
union of the AIS is less than or equal
to the sum of their probabilities this
is again another kind of obvious rule
not hard to prove we're not gonna bother
proving it because it really is obvious
but we will get some mileage out of it
later on so to summarize the key concept
here is a probability space it consists
of a countable set of outcomes the
sample space and a probability function
that assigns values between 0 and 1 to
every outcomes such that the sum of the
probabilities is 1 and when we're using
our tree model and so on our objective
is to construct one of these things
usually the hard part will be verifying
that in fact the way we've assigned
probabilities has the property that the
sum of them is equal to 1